I told you late last week that November
was truly a record-setting month for the
david pakman show and it's funny because
it the trolls in the hay tree it's a
common thing they've been saying lately
is David Trump won your show is ending
that's it just give it up and it could
not be further from the truth it's
actually stunning the month we had last
month and I want to share some of the
details with you number one as far as
podcast downloads over 200,000 podcast
downloads of the full hour david pakman
show uh best thing the prior record from
august of 2016 on uh reddit we had over
22,000 page views which was almost three
times the prior record of 8,000 page
views in october of 2016 now over 2,000
subscribers on the reddit discussion
forum but much more importantly record
traffic there people really really
engaged you can sign up there at the
avett pakman.com slash reddit that's re
d di t record month on youtube the
youtube channel has been doing really
well lately with 5 to 6 million views
per month on youtube but november set a
new record with seven point one five
million YouTube views thank you so much
the prior record 6.9 million in August
of 2016 and also a record for youtube
subscribers 13,000 new YouTube
subscribers in November of 2016 the
prior record was 11,200 dating back to
January of 2016 and very importantly the
number one source of funding for the
david pakman show is paid subscribers i
know i I don't mention membership often
so this is this might be the first time
you've heard about it but we did have
230 view paid subscribers in November
that is roughly twice twice the prior
single month new subscriber records so
thank you so much corporate media
clearly failed us we realize that in the
late hours of november eighth into the
the hours of November 9th we realized it
during the Democratic primary we need to
keep building and what can we do now
will number one if you haven't yet
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership please do I would love it if
November uh is bested by December in
terms of new subscribers based on the
first five days of the month 230 new
subscribers last month on track if we
maintain the current pace we would be at
248 in December so we are on track
please keep that momentum going if the
normal prices are too high I get it six
bucks a month 60 a year it's too much
for many people you can use that coupon
code I voted 17 I voted 17 all one word
all lower case that'll give you a forty
percent discount because I want you
involved at any financial level if the
normal prices are too high use the
coupon code but in addition to that uh
subscribe on youtube if you haven't yet
youtube.com slash the david pakman show
we're targeting 300,000 subscribers
there but the big news is that this week
we are launching a major major
fundraising campaign please get in touch
if you want to be an early donor we're
looking for large early donors who want
to get momentum going early to get in
touch we've got a list of nearly a dozen
at this point thanks to those 12 people
who have expressed interest in donating
early we are going to be uh creating a
new position which is progressive
engagement coordinator they are going to
be actually working on specific
elections and issues that progressive
can activate on rather than just waiting
around for the next election we're going
to get people activated we are going to
put the david pakman show on amazon
prime we are going to create a fully
mobile studio for both filming and
editing the show remotely and we
actually had a set designer in last week
uh really professional guy who has
started to send some ideas for how we
are going to really professionalize the
david pakman show set i was super
impressed with him Pat I mean he brought
in so much in terms of past sets that
he's worked on he was here for like an
hour taking detailed measurements of
things I can't even figure out what
purpose it serves to measure but clearly
this is going to be an incredibly
detailed plan going forward I can't wait
to see the proposals he puts together
yeah and he was even nice enough to say
that our set looks nice now which I
think it does too but I think it's going
to be a lot of improvements and yeah a
lot of that's going to come from the
fundraising efforts I think that was
charitable when he said how great the
set currently looks but that's okay he
he's going to put some really really
good ideas together so please get in
touch the fundraiser is going to start
later this week but we're trying to
assemble this list of key major early
donors get in touch and of course sign
up at david pakman.com slash membership